[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDLER: Chetama,
I'm a little worried
about this intro.
I don't think we, we really
didn't rehearse this at all.
CHET HAASE: [CHUCKLES]
This is going
to come off completely
unscripted, even though we went
over and over and over again.
I think it's very spontaneous.
DAN SANDLER: I'm specifically
worried about the intro though.
CHET HAASE: Hello, and welcome
to What's New in Android.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: We're glad you
could make it into the room.
We're sorry that they put it in
the smallest room at Shoreline.
DAN SANDLER: It's true.
CHET HAASE: So there is
standing room out there.
If there's a seat next to you,
if you could raise your hand so
that people know that there's
still one available someplace.
That would help.
I'm Chet Haase from the
Android UI Toolkit Team.
DAN SANDLER: I'm Dan Sandler
from the Android System UI
Team.
ROMAIN GUY: And I'm Roman
Guy from the Android Team.
CHET HAASE: Again, once again.
ROMAIN GUY: Again.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
But not on his
team, never again.
CHET HAASE: No, no, no.
[LAUGHTER]
No, that mutiny was successful.
And we're not going to
repeat that problem.
So today, we're going to talk
about what's new in Androids.
Specifically, given the timing
of all the Preview stuff
going on, let's talk
about what's new in N.
Or, hello.
There we go.
We could even call it
What's New in Android.
Actually, what we
should actually call
it is What's New-ish in Android.
Because we've talked
about some of this stuff.
And hopefully, everybody here
has the Preview bits already.
And you've been playing with
it, and submitting bugs,
and playing with the new
features and functionality.
So we're going to go over that.
And we're also going to go
over some of the stuff that's
newer in the Developer Freeview
3 and some other related bits.
So let's do it.
So the big question is, what
does N stand for, of course?
I think it stands for-- so
we went Russian this time.
Of course, nyet stands for not
yet or not going to tell you.
What it actually stands for
today, of course, is N Preview.
And in particular, it
stands for N Preview 3.
So let's talk about there's
different ways to slice
and dice the features.
But we thought it'd
be useful to talk
about the ones that the
users can actually see
and the developer side of that.
And then, we'll talk about
the developer-facing features,
the things that are more about
the implementation and the code
behind it.
So why don't we
start with a demo.
[CHEERS]
Yay.
So let's talk about
Constraint Layouts.
This got a brief mention in
the keynote this morning.
Steph was talking about this.
And Romain is going to
show you what's going on.
ROMAIN GUY: So
Constraint Layout is
a brand-new layout for Android.
It's going to be in
Unbundled Library
that you can integrate
in your application
without updating the framework.
It's compatible all the
way back to Gingerbread.
So you can use it
in any app you want.
And it is our first layout that
was designed in conjunction
with the tool itself.
So as we were building the
Layout Manager for Android,
we were also designing this user
experience for Android Studio.
You saw briefly, in the keynote,
it was maybe a little hard
to see.
We have the system
that automatically
infer constraints.
There are different
ways, in this new system,
that you can create a layout.
So here, for instance,
I have a button.
You can see as I move it
around, we give you guidelines.
It shows you, it [? folds ?]
the material design guidelines,
which will show you the
correct margin that you should
use between different widgets.
It shows you the correct
margin between the widget
and the edge of the screen.
Now, if I add a second button,
I can create a constraint
between those two buttons.
And now, they are aligned.
But what's really powerful
in this new layout editor
is that we run the algorithm
behind the Android layout
on in Android Studio at
60 frames per second.
So when I move the
first button, you
can see in real-time what's
happening, how the layout is
resolving all the constraints.
So this should give you a
lot, much faster feedback
on what's going on.
We could also show you before
you create a constraint.
So as I'm dragging
this constraint
to the edge of the
screen, we'll show you
before I release the mouse.
We animate to show you
what's going to happen
if you create that constraint.
I'm sure some of you
have Views RelativeLayout
and might have been surprised
by what happens sometimes when
you just send an extra widget.
And everything just teleports to
a different part of the screen.
So no more.
So it can very quickly
create more constraints
and add my two
buttons at the bottom.
You can also use AutoConnect.
So if I turn it on when I
drop a new button on-screen,
when you see guidelines,
for instance,
in the center of the screen,
if I drop my button here,
the system is going to
create automatically
the constraints for me.
So I don't even have
to do that work.
You can, of course, edit the
constraints after the fact.
You can do flexible sizing so
you can take up all the space
or none of the space.
We also have
percentage-based positioning.
So here, the button
was in the center.
But you can say that you
want to be at, let's say,
25% from the top of the screen.
And it's going to adapt
to your screen dimensions.
There are other features
that we're going
to demo on Friday at 9:00 AM.
For instance, we
have Aspect Ratio
so you can make
your widget always
be a 1:1 aspect ratio of
16:9, whatever you want.
And finally, the
thing that was briefly
previewed in the keynote.
So if I drop a bunch
of widgets on-screen,
let's say a Text Field from the
top, a it TextView for label.
And you going to position
them carefully the way
I want my UI to look like.
I'm going to destroy
all the constraints.
Now, if I just press
this Field Label icon,
it will figure out
what I want it to do.
And my layout just works.
And you're not locked down.
You can keep adding constraints.
You can keep changing
the behavior.
I could add another widget.
Do automatic inference again.
And you have this
authority of process
to help you make sure UI,
create your UI faster.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: Thanks, Romain.
And--
ROMAIN GUY: Oh,
sorry, one more thing.
This is a preview.
We call it the Alpha 1.
It's rough around the edges.
So download the
Android 2.2 Preview.
Play with it.
Please file bugs.
I'll go personally look
at the bug Tracker.
And I'll harass the
engineers to make
sure they fix at least,
hopefully, most of the bugs.
And we have a lot more coming.
We're still going to work on it.
This is by no means
a final version
of the layout and
the Layout Editor.
CHET HAASE: And one
final question--
how much does it cost?
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: 100 kilobytes.
Is that good?
CHET HAASE: [CHUCKLES]
DAN SANDLER: But for you, Chet?
CHET HAASE:
[CHUCKLES] $4 million.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so, yes, go
please play with it.
Give us feedback.
If we can go back to the slides.
It was an awesome demo.
But I'd like to
see slides again.
DAN SANDLER: Hey, good
luck coloring that.
CHET HAASE: Excellent.
Multi-Window, one of the
more visible changes in N
is the ability to actually
have multiple activities
on the screen at one time.
There's two major Modes of
this that you may see around.
One is Split Screen,
side-by-side.
Or if you're running
vertically, top-to-bottom.
So if we go into Recents, we can
see, in the Screen Record here,
you've got the ability
to drag from Recents
into one half of the screen.
And then, the thing
you were doing
is in the other
half of the screen.
And you can tap one of those
to be your second activity.
As you drag around, you'll
notice that the Window Manager
is simply quickly painting
a background color
until you let go.
And then, you get a full
configuration change.
So one of the things that
makes this work basically
out-of-the-box for your apps is
the magic of Android Layouts.
We know how to do
configuration changes.
We know how to adjust
layout based on new sizes
and form factors of the screen.
So the Window Manager is
building on top of that
so that when you go into
the New Size and Force
by the side-by-side layout,
your app simply works.
So go ahead and test it.
Make sure that it
works the way you
want it to in side-by-side
mode or Split Screen Mode.
And use the APIs if you need to.
So you can opt into this.
You are automatically
opted into it by default.
But you can say
that you do not want
to be a Resizeable Activity.
There are some parameters
you can specify about default
and minimal sizing.
And there are some
APIs for you to listen
to to find out when the system
is going into Multi-Window Mode
or whether you are currently
in Multi-Window Mode.
And then finally, if you
are in Multi-Window Mode
and launching another
subactivity that you would like
to be side-by-side
with yours, you
can ask for it to be
Adjacent to yours.
So go, please check that out.
And also, check out the
picture in Picture Modes.
This is the other half of
Multi-Window Mode where
in Android TV, you
now have the ability
to have an activity playing
a picture-in-picture.
So playing a video
full-time while there's
some other activity,
like the launchers
who the user can pick another
piece of content to watch,
at the same time, while
you've got this video playing
in the front screen.
So for both of these
features and lots more,
please go to the Multi-Window
session today at 4:00 PM.
There's a little bit of
activity for picture-in-picture,
basically similar to what
we saw for Multi-Window Mode
to find out when these
things are happening
and what you can do about it.
There is new Drag
and Drop capability.
We've had Drag and
Drop in the platform
since at least Gingerbread.
And we have added to
that capability now.
Because now, you're in
a Multi-Window Mode.
Wouldn't it be nice if you
could drag from one activity
to another?
Which the previous Drag
and Drop Mode did not allow
because it didn't need to.
But now, you want to actually
be able to drag content
back and forth between
these multiple activities.
So we added a little bit
of API and capabilities
to allow you to do that.
So we can see some
of the APIs here.
A lot of it is
around permissions.
Because maybe that
activity didn't actually
want you to copy from
the Password field
onto your own activity.
Or maybe you don't
want that cat video
dropped onto your activity.
So there's a bit of hand-shaking
back and forth to grant
the correct permissions.
And then, there's also ways
to actually start the actions,
to cancel the actions
while they're on the fly,
to update the Drag Shadow, the
very inappropriately-named Drag
Shadow.
That's basically the
thumbnail representation
of the piece of content
that's being dragged around.
So you can update that
to whatever you want.
You can even keep
updating if you really
want to animate the
Shadow representation.
DAN SANDLER: Oh, yeah.
CHET HAASE: If that's a thing.
So we can see a
quick screen record.
You can see this in action here.
Let's see, yeah.
So this is a couple of demos
that we have internally.
This will be published
as an article and demo
that you can run externally.
It just shows the
basic interaction
of dragging something that
doesn't have permissions
versus granting the
permissions and, then,
getting the capability
to drag between the apps.
Moving on.
So we have Notifications.
DAN SANDLER: All right,
so you've all seen
us do this talk before, I hope.
And you know this
is the part where
I hijack the conversation,
for 15 whole minutes,
to talk about all the shiny
new stuff in Notifications.
Well, not this time because
they gave me my own talk.
So come back
tomorrow at 9:00 AM.
And we'll go really deep on
all the exciting new stuff
in Notifications in Android
and in Android Wear 2.0, which
you saw at the keynote.
I will just--
CHET HAASE: Give me
the clicker back now.
DAN SANDLER: No,
I'm not quite done.
Hang on.
[CHUCKLING]
I do want to just highlight
a few things that I want
you to be aware of, perhaps
entice you to come learn more
or check it out in
the developer docs.
First, we have new templates
for the first time,
really, since Honeycomb.
Although we did do
a bit of a material
update a couple of releases ago.
Some new templates,
moving things
around a little bit, creating
new attribution for the app
that sent the notification.
So you always know
who is putting
stuff in front your face.
We also have bundled
notifications,
something that we originally
developed for Android Wear.
Finally available on the
handset and on tablets,
the ability to group those
notifications together.
We also have direct
reply, the ability
to touch the Reply button
and actually just type
the text right in the shade.
So this is, again,
something that Android Wear
has had for a while.
So you could talk to
your watch and have
it sent as a text message.
Now you can do the same thing
even from the lock screen
if the user has allowed it.
While I'm up here and talking
about System UI things,
I would like to talk to you
about Quick Settings We've
finally done
something that users
have been asking for
for a long time, which
is make them editable.
Now allow you to choose to
add and remove the Quick
Settings that you want to see.
And in fact, we have this great
new thing called the Quicker
Quick Settings.
I think I just
came up with that.
The Quicker Quick
Settings is the list
of five, your five top
Quick Settings that
appears at the very top
of the notification list
any time you're looking at it.
So if you move those around
to get the top five in there,
you'll have access to
them one touch away,
any time you're looking
at your notifications.
[APPLAUSE]
But wait.
There's more.
So developers, if you've
been playing along at home,
you know from the
end preview that you
can create your own
Quick Settings tiles now
that any user using Android
N can choose to install.
So go ahead and take
a look at the API docs
around TileService.
This creates a whole lifecycle
around Quick Settings tiles
that allows you to know
when the user has added
the tile to the list, when
the tiles are actually
being looked at.
So if you need to do live
updates, you can do them then.
And then of course,
the all-important
what to do when the
user clicks on the tile.
When you call getQsTile,
you get a pointer
to the tile object, which
actually holds all your State
and lets you do things
like change the icon,
change the label, go into and
out of an active State, which
lets you dim it or
not dim it based
on whether that
resource is available.
And then, once you
make all those changes,
please don't forget
call updateTile.
So this is perfect
for your settings.
Some Quick feature
of an app that you
know the user wants to have
access to from the lock screen.
If you are busy building
out your smart home,
the first thing you want to
do is have a Quick button
from your phone
where you can turn it
on and make it play your theme
music as soon as you walk home.
That's exactly what
Quick Settings is for.
The last thing you have to do
is blah, blah, blah-- stuff
in the manifest--
just to make sure you
get all the correct permissions
so that System UI knows
that you're a
Quick Settings tile
and knows what to do with it.
Let's talk for a little
bit about Display Size.
So this is actually an
accessibility feature
that we're introducing in N
to augment and even replace
Font Size.
So Font Size is something
you've been able to change
on Android for a long time.
Developers, you know that if you
specify your typefaces in ASPI
that multiplies in the
user's chosen Font Size
so you can let the user say,
I need a little bit more help,
or, I want to be able
to see a little bit
more text on the screen.
But what you, as developers,
probably also know
is that that ASPI is
very limited, right?
We don't really change layouts
based on the Font Size.
You can do Wrap Content
to get around that.
But there are certain
parts of the system
like, [CLEARS THROAT]
Notifications,
[CLEARS THROAT]
that really didn't
deal very well with that.
Because the size of
the geometry just
did not change to accommodate
all the additional text.
So what we have now, in Android
N, is a Display Size feature.
You go into the Display
Settings, you hit that.
And it changes the dpi
of the device at runtime.
It becomes a new way to change
all of the UI on the device
to a new density,
not just the text.
So you can blow
everything up or shrink it
all down to make the most use of
that tiny little screen you've
got there.
So you can go from 0.85 all
the way up to almost 1 and 1/2.
I shouldn't have to tell
you this at this point.
But please avoid
px in your layouts.
Because since this is changing
the density of the device,
this is gets multiplied
in when you use dps
in your layouts and
the other computations.
The other thing that
you want to do--
and I'll show you a
video in a second that
makes this really clear-- is
make sure your app works really
well in sw320dp.
I know.
I know we're all carrying
around these giant-like slabs
of phones.
And there are very few
tiny displays out there.
But suddenly, if a user
changes the density such
that the screen is
effectively sw320dp,
now your app needs to deal
with that in a graceful way.
So we've got a video here that
shows actually what happens.
This is the live Resize.
You go into Display Size.
You move the slider
around, Larger and Smaller.
And you can see that
everything changes size,
not just the text, but the
Navigation Bar, Status Bar,
and all that good stuff.
And in fact, I have
the breakdown here.
This is what Default
size looks like.
If you just change the Font
Size, some things get bigger.
But some things are unaffected.
And then, of course, Display
Size changes everything.
So you can finally make
every part of the UI
big enough for you to see
or small enough for you
to feel like you can pack all
that information in there.
Let's talk about Locales.
CHET HAASE: Let's do that.
All right, thanks, Dan.
Multi-Locale.
[APPLAUSE]
No, no, no.
I haven't done it yet.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what's
awesome is seeing
the geometry and the
shape of the awning
based on the empty
seats in the auditorium.
It is really hot
back there, isn't it?
DAN SANDLER: It's a reason
to watch the 360 feed.
CHET HAASE: [CHUCKLES] Yes.
But it's not hot at home
for the live stream.
All right, so for you
people playing at home,
let's talk about Multi-Locale.
This has been a mucrequested
feature for many releases now.
And it turns out that
outside of my country, people
speak more than one language.
[LAUGHTER]
It's true.
I have been told this.
People like you.
And for these people, it's very
difficult to deal with the UI.
Because sometimes you would
like some contents or some apps
to speak to you in one of
those preferred languages,
or to have a different fallback
than some other system default
when it didn't have the
appropriate resources,
whatever.
There's many situations
where you actually
want a set of multiple languages
and locales that it can handle.
So we now have that.
So you can not only select
all these multiple languages,
but you can reorder
them based on what
you want to do in the device.
And you can also add some of
the new languages and variants
that we've added.
So we've got a little
screen record here
where we show how
you select this.
You go into Languages.
I only had one selected.
I don't know why that is.
So let's go in
and pick Deutsche.
It actually means
German, not Dutch, just
for your information.
And I picked the
Liechtenstein variation of,
because I thought
that was funny.
And then I reordered
it and put it on first.
And all of sudden,
I can't read my UI.
Because now that has
become the primary language
for the entire system.
So Multi-Locale, please
go out and use it.
Let's talk about Doze Mode.
So we had Doze Mode in
Marshmallow already.
So I'm going to do
a little review.
I stole a diagram from
the System Health people
so that-- I thought it was
pretty self-explanatory.
I could just pop the
diagram up there.
And you'll
immediately understand
what Doze Mode is about.
It's, I mean, it's
sort of obvious.
But I'll use some
highlights and point out
the important parts of this.
First of all, Doze Mode kicks
in after a while the screen is
off, the device is stationary,
and it's running on battery.
So it runs for a while.
And then, it goes
into this Doze Mode
down there that you can see
the little green section
down there.
And then, there are
these maintenance windows
that come along where now,
all of sudden, activities
are allowed to actually
take part in the system,
and do their normal stuff during
these maintenance windows.
And then, we have
these recurring,
an exponentially
increasing duration
between these
maintenance windows.
And so these happen over time.
And then, in the meantime,
we have these Doze Modes
where the activities
aren't doing much.
There's no network activity.
There's deferred jobs and syncs.
There's no WakeLocks.
It's all good.
It allows the battery
to last a lot longer.
So all of this is
self-explanatory.
But then, let's go
in and talk about N.
So in N, we have
all of that stuff.
But then, we also have this
additional lighter weight
Mode of Doze where now you don't
actually need to be stationary.
So it's also
[? heavy ?] that a phone
can be in someone's pocket
for a very long time and not
actually being used.
So wouldn't it be nice if the
activities weren't consuming
a lot of battery at that time?
So they detect this situation
where it's not stationary.
They wait for a little while.
And then, they go
into the Doze Mode.
And then they have these
maintenance windows.
You have lessened
activity, not as
restrictive as the Marshmallow,
but similar concept here.
And again, all
self-explanatory here.
We'll notice on the diagram
that you have similar colors
for some of the elements there.
It must mean that
they're dozing similarly.
And then finally, we
have similar barcodes.
So all of this makes sense.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's point out that the
capabilities in N, the lighter
weight Doze that I
was talking about,
that's actually a superset
of the functionality already.
We have all the stuff from N
when the device is actually
stationary, plus this lighter
weight all at the same time.
So if we really want
to make sense of it ,
then we put the
diagrams together.
And then, it looks
more like this.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think, as I
said, this is obvious.
[APPLAUSE]
Some people thought I
should use words in more.
So we'll go quickly over that.
In Marshmallow, you
have the device.
The screen is off.
It's on battery.
And it's stationary.
And at that time,
you're restricted
from using the network.
Your deferred job syncs,
alarms, no WakeLocks.
Service is restricted in
N, lighter weight, all
of the above.
But it doesn't have to
actually be a stationary.
It can be moving around in
your pocket or wherever.
And it's then you have
a less of a restriction.
Because there are some
background activity
that's still valid to
take place at that time.
Please go to the Battery and
Memory Optimizations talk
today at 5:00 PM to learn more
details about this as well
as other System Health stuff.
And when I'm talking
about System Health stuff,
let's talk about Project Svelte.
So this is a project that was
started a couple releases ago
to look at all the stuff that
is going on in the system that
is causing the battery to
drain significantly, and then
see what we can tell developers
to do to fix their applications
and address that need, and also
what we can do on the platform
side.
So we did that.
And in N, you can say goodbye
to the following actions.
I'm sure we'll all
miss them terribly.
But they had to go.
So there were these
situations that we detected,
in the research
that that team was
doing, where something
would happen,
like a connectivity action.
A message would occur.
And all these activities
would wake up.
Because they really,
really, really wanted
to know when the
Wi-Fi network changed.
So you're walking around
your corporate building,
moving from one
router to the next.
And all these
activities wake up.
And they say, OK, what's to do?
Nothing.
And then they would
go back to sleep.
And in the meantime,
the system is thrashing.
Because they're all waking up.
They can't all fit in
memory at the same time.
So we're killing off old ones
so that the new ones can start.
And we just get into this
horrible thrashing situation.
Similarly, for new
videos and new pictures,
the user took a picture.
And some expense report
application on your phone
decides, oh, it wants to
know about new pictures.
Because maybe they took
a picture of a receipt.
So the activity wakes up along
with 40 of its best friends.
And realizes that it does
not care about the picture
of the cat that you just took.
And then, it goes back to sleep.
So similar thrashing.
Why don't we reduce that
stuff and make the battery
and lifetime of the device
much better for the user
by simply not sending
those anymore?
Instead, the new approach
is to use JobScheduler,
which we have been talking about
for a couple of releases now.
In particular, there's a new API
that you should pay attention
to that allows you to ask
for when content has changed.
Not immediately, because
that was the problem
with the old approach.
But eventually, when
that job gets scheduled,
then you can find out if there's
new media that you care about.
Again, go to the Battery and
Memory Optimizations session
to learn more about this stuff.
DAN SANDLER: And then,
that app can absolutely
let you expense that cat.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
[CHUCKLES] Yes, it
turns out that that
[INAUDIBLE] was a valid picture
for the expense report.
Yeah, good point.
Thanks.
All right, Data Saver, it is
now possible for the user to--
DAN SANDLER: [INAUDIBLE]
CHET HAASE: --tell the
device, tell the system
that it wants to restrict
the amount of data
that specific apps are using.
So here, in the
place that I live,
I really don't worry
too much about Wi-Fi.
And I'm on a data plan
where I'm not really capped.
It's not that big a deal.
That is not true the
world over, obviously.
People may pay
really high premiums
on their network access.
Or it may be really slow.
So they don't want everyone to
use up the limited bandwidth
that they have.
Or maybe they're metered.
So there, we're giving
them the ability
to really clamp
down on that and not
only tell us to use
less data, but also
to tell specific apps
whether they are allowed
to use data, restricted or not.
So there's a place where you
can go in System Settings
now where you can
basically toggle this
on a per-application basis.
On the developer's side,
that means that you
need to pay attention to this.
Because you may be
restricted at any time.
So there's mechanisms
in the system for you
to find out whether
this is happening
so you can query for the
connectivity service,
and then find out
whether you're A, metered
on a metered network
at the time, and B,
whether Backgrounds
access is actually
restricted at that time.
ROMAIN GUY: Direct Boot, one
of my favorite new features
in Android N. So if you have
a PIN code set on your device,
and you've encrypted the
device, if the device happens
to reboot for some reason--
because you took an update,
or we have automatic
update, or because
of a spontaneous
reboot-- you would
find your device sometimes
sitting on the PIN code screen,
waiting for you to
enter the PIN code.
And you might be missing text
messages, or emails, or even
phone calls.
So now, what the
system does instead,
it will boot all the
way to the lock screen
before asking for your PIN code.
And until you enter
your PIN code,
some applications
will be able to run.
And you can register
your application
to be able to run in this
Direct Boot Mode, which
means that sitting on
that locked screen,
you will have access to
some of the functionalities,
like getting phone
calls or text messages.
So if you want to
know more about it,
if you want to know what you
can do in your application
to enable that Mode,
please attend the talk
on Thursday at 9:00 AM.
It's going to be in the
Android Security talk.
Another feature that's
been widely requested
was access to
specific directories
on the external storage.
So if your application
needs to look
at the pictures, or the music,
or the videos, or whatever
on the user's external
storage, up until now
you had to request access
for the entire storage.
And it was a bit of
a scary permission
for users when they were
downloading the application
from the Play Store.
So now instead, as we see
here in the screenshot,
your application
can specifically
request access to one Directory,
like pictures or just music.
And combined with the new
permission system in N,
it becomes very
clear to the user
what the application
is trying to do
and what the application is
going to be able to access.
CHET HAASE: So
Android for Work, I
would encourage you
go to their session.
There's a lot of
stuff going on there.
I just wanted to
call out a couple
of features in
particular in Android
for Work in this release.
So go to the session Thursday,
2:00 AM, Your Apps at Work.
Please tune into that.
But in the meantime, if you
have a work profile installed
on your phone, there
is a new feature
called Work Mode, which actually
it's about disabling Work Mode.
So it sort of, let's
put an exclamation point
in front of that.
Not Work Mode.
Basically, you can go
into Quick Settings
and easily toggle it off.
And you'll see-- I don't
know if you can see it
on the screen-- the Work
Profile applications were
just disabled.
So if you click on
one of those, you'll
get a little dialog
saying, no, no, no, that's
disabled right now.
So it's easy to turn
that on and off.
So you can spend
the weekend actually
not checking work email
if that's your choice.
There's also something
called Work Challenge, which
can hopefully get away from
some of the ugly authentication
stuff that companies
have had to do.
So they require this
extra restrictive password
stuff on the lock screen.
They don't need to
do that anymore.
Instead, they can
provide a password
that is only used when one of
the Work Profile apps runs.
So we'll see a little
screen record of that.
So you want a Work Profile app.
It confirms your password here.
It launches the app.
Now, if you go in and run
one of the other Work apps,
it just goes
immediately into it.
Because you've
already authenticated
into the entire system.
ROMAIN GUY: So now,
the real reason
why we're here, the
features for developers.
So the first big one was also
mentioned in the keynote.
It's changes to the runtime.
So now, we have a much
faster interpreter, which
means when your
application is installed,
it's not compiled
ahead-of-time like in Lollipop
and Marshmallow.
It's first going to run
into Interpreting Mode.
And when the JIT sees pieces
of code in your application
that run very often, or that
would benefit from a higher
performance, it's going to
kick in and compile things Just
In Time.
Then, when your device
goes into Idle Mode,
we're going to use some of the
information gathered by the JIT
to precompile ahead-of-time
part of the application.
So we're really doing three
things-- interpreter, JIT,
and ahead-of-time compilation.
So it took us a few years.
We tried all three in the past.
So now, we're doing all
three at the same time.
I really recommend that you
attend the talk on Friday
at 1:00 PM from the ART
team, The Evolution of ART.
They're going to give you
way more details about how
all that works.
We also have new
Runtime Libraries.
One of the big new ones, ICU4J,
it's now part of the framework.
ICU is a Library that's
useful for globalization,
internet civilization
of your application.
It's a fairly large Library.
So it's now part
of the framework
with a different
package name so that we
don't clash with the
existing package names.
And you can now rely on
it being in the framework.
So you can reduce
the size of APK.
We also added some new
java.util packages.
So there's
java.util.function that
contains classes and APIs that
are useful for functional style
programming, like Predicates.
We also have the
new Streaming API
that is extremely useful
when you combine it with some
of the new Language Features.
So if you want to use
some of the new Java 8
programming Language Features,
you have to change your gradle
[? build ?] file to switch
to the new Jack compiler.
You also have to say that
you want source and binary
compatibility with the 1.8
version of the programming
language.
And when you do that, you have
access to Lambdas functions.
So Lambdas are implemented using
anonymous in your classes--
speaking too
quickly-- which means
they're backward compatible all
the way back to Gingerbread.
So you have some examples
of what Lambdas are.
If you don't know what they
are, if you've never used them,
there's tons of documentations
and articles online.
Go look at them.
It's going to make
your life a lot better,
especially if you use things
like RxJava or just the Android
UI framework, anything
that requires a lot
of [? re-centers. ?] Lambdas
make it a lot easier.
Just be careful, though,
because those things
create anonymous classes.
They are little more costly
than this seems, than they seem.
But it shouldn't matter
much in most applications.
Default and Static Interface
Methods, two very useful
features that are
not, unfortunately,
backward compatible.
So if you have an
existing interface,
you can now add new methods
and pull our default
implementations,
very much like what
you can do in abstract classes.
Again, very useful to move your
APS forward without breaking
everything or your clients.
And you can even use them
to create the famous adapter
pattern that you've probably
seen with a lot of listeners.
So you have a listener that
has several callback methods.
And typically, there's
an adapter class
that comes next to it
that has just an [? MT ?]
implementation of all these
methods, so that when you want
to implement only
one of the methods,
you don't have to
declare all of them.
So it's very easy to do now
with the default methods.
And you can also have Static
Methods on interfaces.
Repeating annotations,
I'm sure many of you
are using all those fancy
frameworks with tons
annotations, but
love that feature.
It's also, unfortunately,
not backward-compatible.
But it means that now
a single notation--
there's is an example at
the bottom-- @Exportable--
can be written several
times on the same type.
So for instance,
here, we have a class
that we want to be able to
serialize in different formats.
We can just repeat annotation
instead of using arrays
of values in the annotation.
The Audio Team, the Media Team
has been working really hard
in previous versions of Android
to reduce audio latency.
Most of that work previously
was done in the native levels
of the system.
And in end, they worked
reducing the latency of audio
in the upper levels.
So you can expect, depending
on your device of course,
a 40- to 70-millisecond latency
reduction when you play audio.
It's very easy to enable.
There's an example
right here on-screen.
When you create the audio
attributes for your media
player, you can just set
the Flag Low Latency.
And we're going to give you
access to that new feature.
There's also a couple
new APIs that you can
use to improve the playback.
You can create the
number of underruns
that happen while you're
playing your media back.
And you can also
dynamically resize
your buffers to take action when
there are too many underruns.
If you want to
know more about it,
especially if you
want to know how
to use the underlying
native APIs to increase
your latency even further, you
can go to the talk on Thursday
at 3:00 PM.
Renderscript, a bunch
of improvements.
It's now in the
single source file.
You can have many kernels
that cannot call one another.
It makes it a lot
easier to create
complex computes programs.
We also have reduction kernels.
So you can do a Map
Reduce type of API.
For instance, if you need
to compute a histogram,
you can do that with
a reduce kernel.
You have access to
multiple images.
We added
Allocation.getByteBuffer,
which is going to
help you reduce
the number of Allocations that
happen when run a Renderscript
kernel.
And finally, if you do a lot of,
if you process a lot of data,
we have support for
a 16-bit floating
points, which helps you cut
the size of your data in half.
And if the precision
works for you,
you should definitely
look into it.
For graphics people out
there, OpenGL ES 3.2,
that's the newest
version of OpenGL ES
that we ship with Android
N, it is effectively
OpenGL ES 3.1 plus something
that's called the Android
extension pack.
The Android extension pack was
a bundle of OpenGL extensions
that if the
extension pack itself
was present on the device, you
are guaranteed to have access
to all those extensions.
It was making the life of OpenGL
ES developers a lot easier.
So this has been folded into the
actual specification of OpenGL
ES 3.2, except one
of the extensions
that you can see on the slide.
And some of the highlights
include advanced blending
equations.
So now, the hardware can take
care of doing all the blending
Modes that you find in Photoshop
or their Image Processing
Application.
You don't have to write
shaders for that anymore.
It's part of OpenGL.
You can use tessellation
and geometry shaders.
Those are very useful to
generate geometry at run time.
So typically, what you can do is
you have a fairly simple mesh.
And as the camera gets
closer to the object,
you can add more and more
triangles dynamically
to make it look
smoother on screen
without paying a huge
memory cost or performance
cost when you don't need
those extra triangles.
There's a new texture
compression format
called ASTC and a
couple of other features
that, if you use OpenGL ES,
you will care very much about.
Vulkan was also mentioned
in the keynote, so
a little more details.
There's going to be a talk
about it on the, well,
today at 6:00 PM.
So Vulkan's a low-level
API to the graphics.
It's lower-level than OpenGL.
In some way, you effectively
become the driver.
So you can generate
commands for the GPU
from multiple threads,
which is going
to help improve the efficiency
of your application.
There's no, not as much
overhead in the driver itself.
So you can make more draw calls.
You can put more
objects on-screen.
You can also precompile
your shaders offline,
which is very useful
to do validation
or to do heavy optimizations,
because the drivers
on the device try to find a
balance between optimizing
your shaders and not spending
too much time compiling them.
It's also a cross-platform API.
So Vulkan, as it
exists in Android N,
is the same as the Vulkan you
will find on Windows and Linux.
The drivers are shipping today.
So you can even write your
code on your desktop machine,
and then run it on
your mobile device.
It's also a little more
difficult in OpenGL ES.
You have to do explicit memory
management and synchronization.
So we're going probably
see a huge uptick
in Vulkan in middleware.
So engines like Unity
or Unreal Engine
are working on supporting Vulkan
or have support for Vulkan.
So if you're using one of those
engines, you're good to go.
Your apps are going
to be better for free.
CHET HAASE: There
were improvements
to adb in terms of both
functionality as well
as performance.
So we made it a lot
more full-featured, more
like a real shell.
So you can actually get a lot
more content from, let's say,
LS.
You can also take the results
from things that happen in adb
and actually pipe them to
other processes on the host.
So much more full-featured
stuff that you can do with that.
And then, there were also
major performance improvements
made specifically
to push and pull
by a really complex
algorithm known
as increasing the buffer size.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's how we do
things here at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
So--
DAN SANDLER: Go yo--
CHET HAASE: If you knew adb,
you don't really have a choice.
But you'll enjoy it.
ROMAIN GUY: Getting
the process exit status
and being able to pipe
the standard input
to the remote device is
particularly useful to automate
testing, for instance.
You can run a lot of things
automatically on the device
and get the correct results.
All our changes
to the NDK, we've
upgraded Clang to
3.8 and GCC to 4.9.
But even though
we've updated GCC,
this is the last
version of GCC that
will be supported by the NDK.
So if you're still
using GCC, NDK now
it's time to test your
application with Clang.
It's time to move
on, I would say.
And we also made the default,
the arm7 architecture
the default. So you can forget
about the old architecture.
So your banner
is, should benefit
from more
optimizations that make
more sense for today's devices.
CHET HAASE: VR, we
heard a little bit
about that in the keynotes.
And you're going to
hear a little bit more
about that the rest of the week.
I wanted to talk about the
massive servers area of API
that you need to be aware of.
First of all, you need to
know about the features
on the device.
The devices are a little
specific to the capabilities
that they have as we
heard in the keynote.
And then, next, there's this API
that you need to be aware of.
And I would say, for
the rest of the details,
please go to the session.
It turns out, there
are a lot of them.
Last time I looked,
like 18 sessions on VR.
So take your pick.
I think one of the big
ones, where they're
going to talk about some
of the technical details,
are tomorrow morning
at 9:00 perhaps.
But look on the schedule.
You'll know if it uses
the phrase VR in it.
It's kind of a--
DAN SANDLER: Sorry,
was that V, VR?
CHET HAASE: VR.
And notice that's four quotes.
That's not just two.
That's four quotes.
DAN SANDLER: That's four quotes?
OK.
CHET HAASE: On each side.
All right.
ROMAIN GUY: I would
just add if you're not
writing a VR experience,
a game, or virtual museum,
or whatever, this
API is not for you.
Do not turn it on
in your application
just because you
think it's going
to make your app grow faster.
That is not for you.
It's only for VR people.
CHET HAASE:
[CHUCKLES] All right.
Not for you.
ROMAIN GUY: Not for you.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: All right, Support
Library, this is not new in N.
But I wanted to talk
briefly and quickly
about some of the things that
have been in recent releases.
So in the 23.2 release,
we had a bunch of stuff
that people were
looking forward to.
There's Night Mode capabilities.
So the ability for
your application to
quickly toggle between
light and dark themes.
The Bottom Sheets UI
for material design
and Vector/Drawable and
AnimatedVectorDrawable, people
have been asking this since we
released the original feature
on Lollipop, as if
we didn't quite know.
It turns out it was actually
really tricky to implement
because of the way
resources are processed,
as well as drawables,
and making that work
in a backward-compatible way.
Took a while.
But finally, it's there.
It goes back several releases.
So please check those out.
Use them.
And start shipping
APKs that are smaller.
Because vectors tend to be a
lot smaller than equivalent
images-- PNGs and JPEGs.
RecyclerView AutoMeasure,
also Wrap Contents, that
has been a much requested
feature for a while.
So that was in that release.
And then, in 23.1 we made slight
API adjustments to RecyclerView
to allow much more performing,
as well as feature-rich item
animations.
So check those out as well.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes, speaking
of VectorDrawable,
there's going to be a talk
by [? Colt. ?] Don't remember
when.
It's about image
compression and what
you can do to reduce
the size of your APKs.
So he's going to talk
about VectorDrawables,
but also what you
can do with PNGS,
and JPEGs, and WebPs to make
your applications just smaller
and look just as good.
CHET HAASE: Yes, that.
Support Library, I also
wanted to talk about what I
would like to call the future.
There are some exciting things
going on that developers
are going to care deeply about.
But we do have a
session called What's
New in the Support Library.
And instead of
stealing their thunder,
I would say go check out
that session today at 4:00
to learn about some
of the stuff that's
coming up in future
releases in Support Library.
I want to quickly go over these.
Because I like them.
This is kind of an
implementation detail.
Nobody on the outside's
going to know.
But VectorDrawable
performance improved greatly
in the N Preview
release, because we
worked on performance
improvements
on both the loading side as
well as the firstDraw side.
So we create the bitmap.
And we draw it there.
And we were taking a long
time drawing that path.
We sped that up.
We also sped up just
the act of parsing it.
If you have a
really complex path,
it turns out that parsing that
string, at the Java level,
was very time-intensive.
So we have significant
speed-ups there.
More of a reason to start
using VectorDrawables.
Also FloatProperty
and IntProperty,
my favorite features
because I checked them in.
And this really--
ROMAIN GUY: Is that the
only code you wrote for N?
CHET HAASE: Possibly.
ROMAIN GUY: I'm pretty sure.
CHET HAASE: No, no.
Actually, I wrote a
lot of other code.
And I checked it in.
And there were problems.
So I checked it back out.
[LAUGHTER]
Not only did I not
actually write much code
for FloatProperty/IntProperty.
But I actually wrote
it about two years ago.
But it was hidden API.
But we realized
that people really
couldn't access the
capabilities of using primitives
with the property
object until these
were exposed as public API.
So there they are.
Please use them.
Especially for
animations, it allows
you to have a much more direct
method of setting properties
without doing a
typical mechanism, what
we use an animators where we
dive down into JNI and back up.
So it adds a little
performance improvement.
What else we got?
Android Instant Apps, we
saw this in the keynote
this morning.
You saw us go to the Sandbox
area and check out the demos.
And also check out
the talk that they
have tomorrow
morning, What's New
in Android Play for Developers.
And they'll have more
details about that.
And the most important
thing, go get the release.
If you don't have it
yet, Developer Preview 3
should be out there now.
I don't know the
timing of sessions
with when the bits
actually hit the interwebs.
But it should be there.
Please go get it.
Some helpful URLs in case
you don't know d.android.com
is, there it is.
So go get the Preview.
And go set up the SDK.
And most importantly,
please file bugs.
And do it really quickly.
We're trying to
finish this release.
Is there anything else?
ROMAIN GUY: Should
we take, I just
want to tell you couple things
about Constraint Layout.
Because I care deeply about it.
There's also a Code Lab
you can attend if you
want to play with it already.
Other than that, we can
take a couple questions.
It's going to be awkward
in this room, but.
DAN SANDLER: I don't think
we have mics in the audience?
CHET HAASE: I don't
know how we're
going to take questions here.
ROMAIN GUY: Just
speak very loudly.
CHET HAASE: You know what?
I will say for the other 2,000
of you that had questions
that you couldn't
ask, we are going
to have office hours at
the end of every day.
There's an office hours
called Android N Office Hours.
There's actually going to be a
lot of platform people there.
The people that worked
on N, it turns out,
are the same people that worked
on all the other releases.
So please bring your
questions there.
And there's other more
team-specific office hours
for Multi-Window
and stuff like that.
So check it out on the schedule.
And come ask us questions then.
I think we're going
to skip the questions.
ROMAIN GUY: All right.
CHET HAASE: It's just
kind of awkward there.
So why don't we wrap it up.
And we'll say thank you.
ROMAIN GUY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
[ELECTRONIC THEME MUSIC]